avoid the following mistake the most
common mistake of investing thinking
that the investment that did good
is a good investment
people rather more expensive
the things that quite often
those markets that did really really
well became more more expensive and
everybody smart money is all the time
compete comparing them and competing
so what happens is
um the naive money
buys the thing that was hot or is hot
the thing that has been terrible which
might be the thing that's beaten down
so I would say also an important element
okay so here's another one that's really
important
diversify
so don't put all your eggs in one basket
right because what I learned about this
is that first of all all Investments
uh compete and it's not easy to sell
tell whether one investment's better
than the other because if people could
do that life would be easy and
everybody'd make a ton of money
um so and this is a competitive game
that's very difficult to compete in so
it's very difficult to say which one's
better or worse you could take experts
and you could and do all sorts of tests
and you'll find out that they can pick
that and you can't tell whether the
worst ones are going to be better so
because of that you understand that um
even picking the best ones is difficult
and particularly if you're naive like we
spend hundreds of millions of dollars
each year on Research to try to give us
an edge okay now you've got to compete
with us so uh competing in the markets
is more difficult than competing in the
Olympics you wouldn't both think I'm
going to compete in the Olympics but
there are more people who try harder in
order to do that so it's a zero-sum game
so but diversification
um that they're different uh will reduce
your risk without
um reducing your return